technology is being used to define us in
its criminalizes Congress is required
biometric entry exit visa tracking
systems so that's the yeah in federal
thieves terrorists you know they've all
come across our cameras being done with
no oversight no regulation its facial
recognition being used to over police
people like you
[Music]
and now touch that and get your just
faces so now I'm enrolled tonight I just
touch it get my face there whoa that was
quick
I was less than a second I managed have
a Dean and I came here to learn how
facial recognition is evolving rapidly
through smartphones machine learning and
algorithms we have tons of different
threats coming everywhere yeah so it is
very very critical that we do have
strong security in place I learned that
facial recognition is replacing
passwords and fingerprints preventing
online identity theft and increasing
security banks are really looking into
this for multiple of reasons one is they
definitely want to reduce fraud but
there are concerns about the
technology's accuracy and bias members
of law enforcement have facial
recognition on their cell phones with
little regulation over how it's actually
used San Diego's Police Department is
one of many in the u.s. that use facial
recognition it's also Erin Harvey's home
this is Lincoln Park so you have
memories all over these yes yes growing
up there wasn't a point in time where I
didn't know everyone who lived on almost
every street when Aaron hit his teens
the city became two different worlds
police began stopping him frequently
today he organizes against gang
documentation Aaron tells me facial
recognition was used on him during one
police stop in 2013 while he was trying
to get to work I'm like look man I got
my license registration insurance I
don't even know why you're pulling me
over Aaron says police insisted they
take his photo so I wouldn't take all
right so then they put me in the car
that's when he was out okay looking you
gonna take this picture you're gonna go
to jail what went through your mind
as he was taking in the picture do you
remember III hope that they're not
trying to connect me into something
right because why you need my picture
San Diego police declined to be
interviewed for this story and told AJ
plus they have no records of using
facial recognition on Aaron Aaron told
me he's been stopped by police so many
times that he no longer counts you think
he brought a bat
I your hearts racing uuuu almost kind of
like so you got concrete boots on you
almost can't even move he immediately
mobilized because it's a terrifying
experience facial recognition software
creates data points that compare facial
features databases are built from
driver's licenses mug shots and
surveillance video the initial
technology was developed in the 1960s
today it's replacing fingerprinting and
police lineups facial recognition
databases used by law enforcement in the
u.s. include 117 million adults that's
one in three Americans I met up with
Claire Garvey co-author of the perpetual
lineup she's a leading expert on how law
enforcement uses facial recognition you
have to start being aware that a
photograph is no longer just a
photograph it's a it's a point of
identity Claire says facial recognition
will have a larger impact on people of
color and women face recognition was
originally a military technology that
was deployed in Iraq and Afghanistan and
we haven't really thought through the
process of oh we start deploying it
domestically what are the different
considerations or do we justify it the
exact same as we did in a conflict zone
a year after Aaron was photographed by
police he was arrested in a gang
conspiracy case do you think facial
recognition factored into you being
implicated most definitely right Aaron
says the District Attorney's Office used
police stops and photos to frame him as
a gang member it concerns me that you
know we are being we're becoming
normalized to being surveilled and also
traumatized he spent nearly seven months
in jail before the case was dropped due
to lack of evidence
was it as rough as I would imagine I'm
lived in a war zone for seven months
@k BLK radio Aaron is a regular guest
who speaks out against gang
documentation I went on air with his
friends to discuss facial recognition
and over-policing
[Music]
20 seconds 20 seconds 26 and evil
law-enforcement agencies used facial
recognition software are on more than
20,000 600 occasions so no so they're
just there just yet collecting data yeah
the police are a data collection agency
there's no clarity to their tactics at
all so I like they're holding seminars
or senior public service announcements
in the schools just for now I mean
there's not they're not informing you
love nothing but when they stop you they
don't tell you why or what the rights
are parents marry stuff tell you kids
they do not have to have their picture
taken because they give them 15 16
year-olds and get their picture taken
and they so scary shook up that they
just do it yeah what we're looking for
is to be able to get about a hundred
pixels between the eyes
I wanted to understand why law
enforcement uses facial recognition so I
sat down with Peter trep the chief
executive officer of face first the
company creates a mobile facial
recognition app used by law enforcement
they've got a pretty long range they can
you know get get a 80 to 100 feet away
from the subjects we've caught a number
of just really bad people out there and
really yeah absolutely I mean child
predators federal thieves terrorists you
know they've all come across our cameras
facial recognition developers say the
technologies become more accurate with
the advancement of machine learning
cops are put in all kinds of very
difficult positions every single day
I think if if they can get the tool in
their hands that helps them know who
they're talking to
and what that person may be all about
what their intentions are or what their
history is I think that helps them do
their job better we will have a proper
tracking system it will be on land it
will be on sea it will be in air we've
all heard about how President Donald
Trump wants to build a massive new wall
here on the border with Mexico to crack
down on immigration but what you might
not know is he also wants to build a
virtual wall with facial recognition to
track people crossing the border the
technology was piloted at the border in
2015 but records show that Immigration
and Customs Enforcement had one of the
lowest match rates in the region last
year the Department of Homeland Security
asked companies in Silicon Valley to
research technology that could identify
people through the windows of cars
crossing the border accuracy is an issue
and low-quality images can lead to
mismatches in London when police tested
the technology at an African Caribbean
celebration it had a two percent
accuracy rate but in China the
technologies become so advanced that
authorities identified a person in a
crowd of 60,000 people at night
the Chinese police released this video
filmed at a concert in Nanjing city the
man traveled 56 miles to the concert
with his wife the Chinese government
accused him of economic crimes the
applications for face recognition are
really open to the imagination of the
agencies that have access to these
databases student activists organized a
protest last fall to voice opposition to
police and border patrol brutality now
led to a student faculty development of
a new combined black Chicano history
class now we need to find ways to work
together
in order for both of our people to be
liberated on our last stop I had two
pillars of the community we're hearing
organizers with halide Alexander we've
seen lessons from the war on drugs and
gain documentation all of these things
and how they intersect is it possible to
think that facial recognition technology
won't be used by law enforcement in this
country no I don't think it's too late I
think there's always an opportunity to
fight back and to push back against
these types of systems mm-hmm Aaron
still has nightmares of getting pulled
over again by police I don't think we
needed law enforcement has enough tools
they're just casting a wide net we don't
want this we're not we didn't even ask
for it the work of an organizer is
draining but he continues to speak out
I'm angry scared terrified fray paranoid
anything negative you could possibly
think of emotions that I feel I'm about
them having missed our technology why
was my freedom taken away from hey guys
it's Emma that was episode one of our
five-part series on the dark side of
tech be sure to watch the rest of the
series and don't forget to subscribe to
aj+